Hi.
Welcome back to recitation.
In lecture you introduced
the idea of differentials
and learned how to compute them.
So I have a couple examples
here for you to do.
So compute the
differential d of 7
u to the ninth plus 34 minus
5 u to the minus third.
And d of sine
theta cosine theta.
So why don't you take a
minute, work those out
and we'll come back and
we'll work them out together.
All right, welcome back.
So hopefully you had
some luck with these.
Let's go through them.
So right, so a
differential is really,
it's just another
notation for something
you already know how to do.
So it's another way of
keeping track of a derivative.
The thing we don't write is
we don't write the over the d,
the variable we're
differentiating
with respect to.
So we pick that
up from what we're
taking the differential of.
So in this case, we
look at this expression.
Let's do the first one first.
So we look at d 7 u to the
ninth plus 34 minus 5 u
to the minus third.
And we just can distribute
that d through in the same way
that we can with
ordinary derivatives.
So OK, so this is
equal to 7 d of u
to the ninth plus d of 34 minus
5 d of u to the minus third.
And now we just
do the chain rule.
So here d of u to the ninth
is 9 u to the eighth du.
So that du comes out of that
chain rule that we're doing.
So this is equal to-- so
well, 7 and we drop the 9
down-- so that's 63 u
to the eighth du plus--
well OK, d of 34,
34 is a constant.
It just kills it.
That's 0.
Minus 5 d of u to
the minus third.
So again, u to the minus third.
That's just a power of u.
We apply our usual rule for it.
So it's minus 3 u
to the minus 4 du.
du from the chain rule.
Again, and so we have minus
5 times minus 3 is plus 15.
Good, so I get to
keep my plus sign.
Plus 15.
What did I say? u
to the minus 4 du.
And so that's all
there is to that.
Now let's do the
second example here.
We have sine theta cosine theta.
So same exact idea.
Here we have a product
rule as our first step.
So OK, so we take the derivative
of the first times the second.
So the derivative-- the
differential of the first,
I should say.
Right?
So the product rule
for differentials
is just the same as the
product rule for derivatives
except instead of
taking derivatives
you take differentials.
So the differential of sine
theta is cosine theta d theta.
And then times the second.
Plus the first, sine theta,
times the differential
of the second, which is
minus sine theta d theta.
OK.
And now if we like, we can, you
know, put this all together,
factor out the d
theta to the end.
And we can rewrite this
as cosine squared theta
minus sine squared
theta d theta.
And of course you could rewrite
this a bunch of other ways
using your trig identities.
Just like you could have started
by writing sine theta cosine
theta as 1/2 sine of 2*theta
before taking the differential.
All right, so that's really
all there is to that.
So there you go.
Differentials.
I'll end there.